et la plupart de ces maltraitances sont commises
par des proches ou par la famille.
Voici Vicky.
Vicky a installé un portail en fer à l'entrée de sa chambre
et elle est devenue une prisonnière dans sa propre maison,
de peur que son neveu ne transforme sa demeure en repère de drogue.
Et voici Mary.
Mary a utilisé une caméra pour la première fois de sa vie
lorsqu'elle avait 65 ans,
et elle a demandé à Vicky et à 99 autres personnes
qui ont été victimes de maltraitance de raconter leur histoire par caméra.
Je suis néerlandaise,
et aux Pays-Bas, nous sommes assoiffés de vérité.
C'est une merveilleuse chose durant l'enfance,
parce qu'il est facile de ne subir aucune conséquence.
Par exemple : « Oui, maman, c'est moi qui ai fumé les cigares. »
(Rires)
Mais je pense que c'est pour cette raison que j'ai consacré ma vie
à promouvoir ces vidéos qui dénoncent des violations des droits de l'Homme,
car je crois en leur pouvoir de montrer des réalités indéniables.
Mon organisation, WITNESS,
a œuvré pour que les vidéos congolaises
aident à l'inculpation et l'incarcération d'un chef de guerre nommé Thomas Lubanga.
Et les vidéos réalisées par Mary,
nous avons formé Mary et d'autres défenseurs des personnes âgées,
pour nous assurer que les histoires d'abus des personnes âgées
atteignent les législateurs,
et ces histoires ont aidé à convaincre les législateurs
pour qu'ils passent des lois afin de protéger les Américains âgés.
Je me demande donc,
des millions d'entre nous possèdent ce puissant outil à portée de main :
une caméra.
Pourquoi ne sommes-nous donc pas une armée de témoins plus influents,
comme le sont Mary et Bukeni ?
Pourquoi l'émergence de tant de contenus vidéo
ne mène pas à plus de droits et plus de justice ?
Je pense que c'est parce qu'être un témoin oculaire est difficile.
Votre récit sera démenti.
Votre vidéo sera noyée dans une mer de contenus multimédia.
Votre histoire ne sera pas crue et vous deviendrez une cible.
Comment aider les témoins ?
À Oaxaca au Mexique,
les enseignants ont organisé une manifestation
après que le président a appuyé des réformes non démocratiques.
La police fédérale est arrivée et a ouvert le feu sur les manifestants.
Au moins sept personnes sont décédées et beaucoup ont été blessées.
Des images de la fusillade ont commencé à circuler,
et le gouvernement mexicain a fait comme à son habitude.
Il a fait une déclaration officielle,
où il accusait simplement les médias indépendants
de créer des fausses images.
Il disait : « Nous n'étions pas là,
nous n'avons pas tiré,
ceci n'est pas arrivé. »
Mais nous avions formé des militants au Mexique
à utiliser les métadonnées stratégiquement avec leurs images.
Les métadonnées sont les informations que votre caméra enregistre
qui montrent la date, le lieu,
la température, la météo.
Cela peut même indiquer la manière dont vous tenez votre caméra
quand vous capturez quelque chose.
Les images ont commencé à re-circuler,
cette fois avec les données
validant la scène.
Le gouvernement est donc revenu sur sa déclaration.
La justice pour le peuple d'Oaxaca
est encore bien loin,
mais leurs histoires, leurs vérités, ne peuvent plus être démenties.
On a donc pensé :
et si on avait un « Mode Preuve » ?
Et si tout le monde avait une caméra à la main
et que toutes les plateformes avaient cette possibilité de validation ?
Nous avons alors développé, avec des développeurs géniaux
du « Guardian Project »,
nous avons conçu une technologie nommée « Mode Preuve »,
qui relie ces métadonnées à votre film,
et valide et vérifie votre vidéo.
Maintenant, imaginez ce déluge d'images
venant des téléphones du monde.
Imaginez, si cette information pouvait être légèrement plus fiable,
quel potentiel ce serait pour les journalistes,
les enquêteurs des droits de l'homme,
les avocats des droits de l'homme.
Nous avons donc partagé le Mode Preuve à nos confrères au Brésil
un superbe collectif de médias appelé Colectivo Papo Reto.
Le Brésil est un lieu rude pour les droits de l'homme.
La police brésilienne tue des milliers de personnes chaque année.
Les seules fois où une enquête est ouverte, c'est...
Devinez.
Quand il y a une vidéo.
Eduardo, 17 ans, a été tué en plein jour
par la police de Rio,
et regardez ce qu'il se passe après qu'ils l'ont tué.
Ils placent une arme dans la main du garçon,
ils tirent deux fois avec l'arme,
(Coup de feu)
pour fabriquer leur histoire de légitime défense.
La femme qui a filmé la scène était un témoin très courageux,
et elle a dû se cacher après avoir posté cette vidéo
par peur pour sa vie.
Mais les gens filment, et ils n'arrêteront pas de filmer.
Nous travaillons maintenant avec des collectifs de médias
pour que des résidents, sur WhatsApp,
reçoivent fréquemment des conseils :
comment filmer prudemment,
comment publier la vidéo prudemment,
comment filmer une scène pour qu'elle puisse compter comme preuve.
Et voilà une inspiration
venant du groupe Mídia Ninja au Brésil.
L'homme sur la gauche est un gendarme lourdement armé.
Il avance vers un manifestant -
quand vous manifestez au Brésil, vous pouvez être arrêté, ou pire,
et il dit au manifestant : « Regarde-moi,
je vais te fouiller maintenant. »
Et le manifestant est un activiste en train de diffuser en live.
Il porte une petite caméra et dit au militaire :
« Je vous regarde,
et il y a 5 000 personnes qui vous regardent avec moi. »
Là, c'est un retournement de situation.
Les témoins à distance, le public, a une importance.
On s'est donc demandé
s'il était possible de tirer profit de ce pouvoir,
du pouvoir des témoins à distance ?
Et si on pouvait utiliser leur expertise, leur influence,
leur solidarité, leurs capacités
quand une communauté en première ligne a besoin qu'ils soient là ?
Nous avons commencé à développer un projet appelé « Mobilize Us »,
parce que beaucoup d'entre nous, je dirais,
veulent aider
et apporter leurs capacités, leur expertise,
mais nous sommes souvent absents quand une communauté
ou un individu fait face à un abus.
Et cela pourrait être si simple avec cette application que nous avons créée
qui montre au coupable de l'autre côté du téléphone
combien de personnes le regardent.
Imaginez que vous pouviez mettre une couche de tâches informatiques
en plus de tout ça.
Imaginez que vous êtes une communauté victime d'un raid d'immigration,
et qu'à ce moment, ce moment précis, avec une vidéo en live,
vous pouviez atteindre cent observateurs juridiques.
Quel impact cela aurait sur la situation ?
Nous avons commencé à construire ceci avec nos partenaires au Brésil.
Cette femme se nomme Camilla,
- elle est à la tête d'une favela nommée Favela Skol -
elle a pu attirer des témoins à distance
par live-stream
pour aider à la traduction,
à la distribution,
et à l'amplification de son histoire
après que sa communauté a été expulsée de force
pour faire place à un événement olympique l'été dernier.
Nous parlons des témoignages positifs,
mais qu'arrive-t-il si les coupables filment ?
Que se passerait-il si un passant filmait mais ne faisait rien ?
C'est l'histoire de Chrissy.
Chrissy est une femme transgenre
entrant dans un McDonald dans le Maryland
pour utiliser les toilettes pour femmes.
Deux adolescentes l'ont battue pour avoir utilisé les toilettes femmes
et l'employé de McDonald a filmé la scène avec son portable.
Il a posté la vidéo,
et elle a provoqué
des milliers de commentaires racistes et transphobes.
Nous avons donc commencé un projet « Capturing Hate ».
Nous avons pris un petit extrait de vidéos de témoins
qui montraient un abus de personnes transgenres ou non-conformes.
Nous avons cherché deux mots, « bagarre de travesti » et « bagarre de bonhommes ».
Et ces 329 vidéos ont été regardées et sont encore regardées
en ce moment même,
presque 90 millions de fois,
et il y a des centaines de milliers de commentaires sur ces vidéos,
provoquant plus de violence et de haine.
Nous avons développé une nouvelle méthodologie
qui a pris toutes ces preuves visuelles non quantifiées
et les a transformées en données, en transformant la vidéo en données,
et avec cet outil,
les associations LGBT utilisent maintenant ces données
pour défendre leurs droits.
Nous avons pris ces données pour les rapporter à la Silicon Valley,
et nous leur avons dit :
« Comment est-t-il possible
que ces vidéos soient toujours en ligne
dans un climat de haine,
qu'elles appellent à plus de haine,
qu'elles créent plus de violence,
quand vous avez des règles qui disent
que vous interdisez ce type de contenu ? »
pour les pousser à changer leurs politiques.
Ainsi, j'ai de l'espoir.
J'espère que nous pourrons changer plus de vidéo en plus de droit, de justice.
Dix milliards de visionnages vidéo sur Snapchat,
par jour.
Et si nous pouvions faire de cette génération Snapchat
des témoins citoyens, efficaces et prudents ?
Et s'ils pouvaient devenir les Bukeni de cette nouvelle génération ?
En Inde, des femmes ont déjà commencé à utiliser les filtres Snapchat
pour protéger leur identité dans des cas de violence domestique.
[Ils m'ont torturée chez moi et ne me laissent jamais sortir.]
La grande vérité qui n'est adaptée à aucun TED Talk,
est que combattre les abus des droits humains est difficile.
Il n'y a pas de solution facile pour ces abus.
Et il n'y a aucune technologie
qui pourra arrêter les responsables.
Mais pour les survivants,
pour les victimes,
pour les communautés marginalisées,
leurs histoires, leurs vérités, comptent.
Et c'est là que la justice commence.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)